[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the harry potter films in the
context of money now at the end of the
day in spite of all the magic that the
harry potter films introduced we do have
to remember that these films needed to
make money in order to continue if the
films flopped then we wouldn't have
gotten any more the books were a massive
success but that certainly didn't ensure
the success of the films as we've seen
plenty of film adaptations fail in other
franchises in november 2001 the film
adaptations of harry potter began
beginning with harry potter and the
philosopher's stone this was the
beginning of a new era and a market for
film dominated by jk rowling's works
over the course of time 20 years to be
exact with 10 films released to date
including fantastic beasts the harry
potter franchise has collectively
grossed over 9.18 billion dollars in the
box office making it the third most
successful film franchise behind star
wars and the marvel cinematic universe
however with all of that said there must
have been some films that did better
than others right the best books didn't
necessarily end up being the best films
and some of the best films ended up
being a challenger for their book
counterpart in today's video i'm going
to be ranking the harry potter films by
their box office earnings deciding once
and for all which film was most
successful let's get started 10.
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald the second installment of
the fantastic beasts series fantastic
beasts the crimes of grindelwald was
released in 2018 it was a follow-up to
the introductory fantastic beasts film
fantastic beasts and where to find them
which was released two years prior the
fantastic beast films haven't received
too much love since their inception and
their box office earnings pale in
comparison to most of the harry potter
films but that didn't entirely stop the
success of the film despite all the hate
that the crimes of grindelwald got it
still has a 6.5 rating on imdb and
successfully grossed over 650 million
worldwide not quite as bad as it was
painted out to be i should add that i
actually enjoyed the film just not
nearly as much as the original films 9.
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
the prisoner of azkaban was the third
installment in the harry potter series
and was released in 2004 it followed the
chamber of secrets which was released
just two years prior i was surprised by
the position of this film for three
reasons first of all it fell behind one
of the fantastic beasts films which
seems odd given how popular the original
franchise is relative to the new films
second of all the prisoner of azkaban
book was great thirdly the film has an
average rating of 7.9 on imdb from over
500 000 votes with all of that said
however the film still wasn't a flop
grossing more than 797 million worldwide
eight fantastic bees somewhere to find
them fantastic beasts and where to find
them was the first film installment in
the new fantastic beasts franchise and
was released in 2016.
the release of the film was quite
exciting as it came five years after the
last harry potter film deathly hallows
part 2 was released ending the veritable
harry potter drought despite an
abundance of negative reviews the film
still ended up garnering a score of 7.3
on imdb a score of 74 on rotten tomatoes
and grossing more than 814 million
worldwide beating out the prisoner of
azkaban i very much enjoyed the film and
though it had a different feel from the
original harry potter films i can
appreciate it as its own entity 7. harry
potter in the chamber of secrets harry
potter and the chamber of secrets was
the second installment in the harry
potter film franchise and was released
just one year after the first film in
november of 2002 the film was a massive
success and was a great follow-up from
the philosopher's stone which was
released just one year prior to date the
film has a score of 7.4 on imdb and a
very respectable 82 percent on rotten
tomatoes with a budget of 100 million
dollars filmmakers took this production
very seriously unfortunately it paid off
as the film ended up grossing more than
879 million dollars worldwide 6. harry
potter and the goblet of fire harry
potter and the goblet of fire was the
fourth installment in the harry potter
film franchise and was released in the
summer of 2004 following the less
successful prisoner of azkaban which
came one year prior though fans showed
less interest in the film leading up to
this one it certainly didn't stop them
from flocking to the theaters the
following year the goblet of fire
received a 7.7 on imdb and an amazing 88
on rotten tomatoes
making it the most successful film score
wise in the list so far with an
increased budget of 150 million the film
ended up grossing more than 896 million
worldwide narrowly beating out the
chamber of secrets by 17 million
five harry potter and the half blood
prince harry potter and half blood
prince was the sixth installment in the
harry potter film franchise and was
released in 2009 with filming beginning
as early as 2007. the film followed the
order of the phoenix which was released
two years prior at the time of the
film's release it broke the record for
the biggest single day worldwide gross
earning 394 million in just five days
the film went on to gross 934 million in
total becoming the then 8th highest
grossing film of all time despite the
film's commercial success many book fans
did not take to this film however that
certainly didn't stop the film's overall
success earning a 7.6 on imdb and 84 on
rotten tomatoes the budget for this film
was astounding 250 million for harry
potter and the order of the phoenix
harry potter and the order of the
phoenix was the fifth installment of the
harry potter film franchise and was
released in 2007 coming two years after
the goblet of fire in 2005. the film
boasted an impressive 150 million dollar
budget but thanks to harry potter's
massive history of commercial success
was able to open with 333 million in
just its first five days the film ended
up with a 77 on rotten tomatoes and a
7.5 on imdb as well as a staggering 942
million in total box office earnings
interestingly enough however warner bros
reported a net loss for the film of 167
million the reason being a bad case of
hollywood accounting 3. harry potter and
the philosopher's stone harry potter and
the philosopher's stone was the very
first installment of the harry potter
film franchise and was released in 2001
this film was particularly special as it
set the standard for the films in the
years to come if you're my age or
anywhere near my age then this film was
probably a huge part of your childhood
and brings with it an immense level of
nostalgia despite this being the very
first film filmmakers still didn't spare
any expense and worked within a hefty
125 million budget the film ended up
with a 7.6 on imdb 81 on rotten tomatoes
and a staggering 975 million in total
box office earnings
2. harry potter and the deathly hallows
part 1. harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 1 was the 7th installment
in the harry potter film franchise and
was released in 2010 following the half
blood prince the film boasted an immense
250 million dollar budget and follows
the trio in their penultimate struggles
against the forces of voldemort the film
ended up with an impressive 7.7 on imdb
77 on rotten tomatoes and over 977
million in total box office earnings
narrowly beating out the philosopher's
stone 1. harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 2. in perfect harmony the
final installment of the harry potter
film franchise the deathly hallows part
2 ended up making the most money of all
of the films the film was released in
2011 just one year after part 1 and upon
being released claimed the worldwide
weekend box office record earning
483.2 million this was the first film to
pass the billion marker and over its
life ended up grossing more than 1.3
billion worldwide and that's it for this
video do you guys think that this order
makes sense in terms of the film's
success this certainly isn't how i'd
rank the films in terms of preference
but i'd like to hear what you guys think
comment your top 10 down below until
next time it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]